it was such a normal morning almost
comically uneventful for the first time
in what felt like forever the morning
newscasts had very little to say they
covered fashion week some protests in
the capital a new health craze sweeping
the nation a funny viral video of a dog
eating a pancake the inspirational story
of a young boy from the midwest beating
cancer a minor political scandal out of
tallahassee florida that nobody would
remember in a week a round of interviews
with an expert who'd written a new book
about the long-term effects social media
might have on our children none of them
knew back then that long term was a
luxury they couldn't afford people went
to work to school some took the day off
plenty took walks or jogs deciding to
exercise outside for a change after all
it was such a beautiful sunny day out
what a terrible shame it would be to
waste the light indoors people were
sleepwalking so placidly blissfully
unaware of what was rattling down the
tracks towards them it was an
uncharacteristically slow day down at
site-19 there hadn't been any
containment breaches in over a week a
couple of new anomalies had been brought
into containment one safe class and one
euclid but neither were the kind that
was likely to bring the scp foundation
any trouble right now the biggest threat
facing their employees seem to be
boredom and they definitely take that
over any other members of their rogues
gallery dr bright poured himself a mug
of nice hot coffee and decided to watch
some tv in the break room just to pass
the time the president of the united
states was giving a press conference on
the white house lawn surrounded by
microphones it was really nothing
special just the same inane babble about
how he was going to fix the deficit and
with inflation on the rise we'd all need
to work on being more fiscally
responsible the immortal foundation
researcher sipped his coffee
these normal boring problems felt like
the perfect escape from the insanity he
needed to deal with every day at the
foundation the president was saying
something about the importance of
families and about farmers being the
nation's real backbone when something
happened there was an odd shift in the
quality of the light dr bright barely
registered it maybe it was something to
do with the cameras however things
started to get stranger the president's
speech began to slur as though he'd just
been pumped with enough morphine to take
down an elephant but it wasn't just that
he was sweating buckets too wet patches
expanded all over his suit and
perspiration was dripping off his skin
dr bright was in suspense was he about
to watch the president have a stroke
live on air would he be called in to
replace him yet again but no the
situation unfolding was far far worse
the president of the united states
slumped forward over his podium while
the reporting corps screamed his face
slopped off his skull like melting wax
the president's words slurring off into
infinity it was the worst a u.s
president had looked on film since
scp-1981
dr bright dropped his coffee cup it
tumbled and shattered onto the ground
below the camera fell as the operator
screamed it pointed down into the crowd
where the reporters were shrieking in
pain and terror steam coming off their
bodies with a sudden intense climb and
heat they were all melting all of them
were melting before his very eyes
broadcast out to how many people it
would be the mother of all containment
nightmares little did dr bright know
that wasn't even the half of the true
horrors unfolding alarms went off across
every containment site in the world any
scp foundation employees unlucky enough
to be standing outside at the time were
lost in the rapidly unfolding horrors
they screamed as the sun cleaved their
atoms apart reducing them into
semi-liquid states without the mercy of
death people lucky to be just out of the
sun could only watch as those less
fortunate disintegrated across the
ground in unholy shrieking puddles never
had such a normal day been thrown into
such terrifying chaos in so little time
billions of voices cried out at once as
the sun changed in the sky above them
since the dawn of humanity it had given
us everything white to baskin warmth to
keep us safe and the life of the plants
and animals that kept us fed it had been
worshipped as a god by countless
cultures over thousands of years one
great mother to all of humanity and now
that mother was drowning us in the
bathtub and perhaps the most frightening
part of all it was for seemingly no
reason no reason at all the scp
foundation was forced to now break their
silence forever the masquerade the veil
it melted along with so much of humanity
they took over every communications
channel in the world and did what they
could to inform people on how to get out
of harm's way stay inside wrap yourself
in sun shielding clothing and only move
at night air travel is preferable if
possible if you can make your way to one
of the scp foundation's secure sites
their only chance of preserving humanity
and figuring out how to reverse this new
nightmare now more than ever the scp
foundation would be humanity's only hope
until of course there was another
terrifying twist in the tale while those
who were melted into piles of living
flesh sludge were sadly assumed to be
lost even the foundation didn't expect
the transformed humans to become a
threat in and of themselves just as
their bodies were melted so were their
minds they became slaves cultists of the
growing tyrant hanging up above
some would coagulate into huge flushing
masses horrifying threats that would
seek out victims overpower them and drag
them out into the light to be absorbed
and transformed
even those hiding inside foundation
containment centers weren't safe these
behemoths of melted flesh would find
their way in using their many twisted
voices to slowly break the minds of
their victims then gather them up with
great flesh tendrils and yank them out
into their doom little by little the
numbers of humanity dwindled it looked
like we had a bright future ahead of us
and in this particular context that's
far from a good thing survivors for
whatever time they had left would
forever remember this walking nightmare
the foundation dubbed it scp-001
to reflect its ultimacy but to everyone
else it had a different name when dave
rakes in a world where anything but
darkness will kill you is there anywhere
left on earth that's truly safe from the
horrors of scp-001
five months into the never-ending horror
of the solar singularity alice spooned
herself a bowl full of warm swedish
meatballs delicious she was part of an
investigative detail from a nearby
community deep within the bowels of the
only truly safe place for human beings
on planet earth
scp-3008 also known as the infinite ikea
no sun had ever shown in there only the
lights which fizz and flicker far above
everyone inside thinks of it as a prison
little do they know what's left of
humanity out there would kill to be
inside the sanctuary alice had a team of
10 with her their mission was simple
continue the mapping effort of the area
surrounding their community and collect
rations for the rest of the camp it was
dangerous work especially as night drew
clothes but there were certain rewards
when they reached a feeding station they
were able to enjoy fresher food than
anyone else all they needed to do was
wager their lives for it to alice it
seemed like a fair trade her lieutenant
darcy kept watched to the north he and
several others wielded makeshift spears
made from curtain rods and clubs
fashioned from bed posts knives
scavenged from the kitchen section hung
from their belts in makeshift holsters
during the day they were little more
than a precaution at night it could mean
the difference between life and death
speaking of darcy kept a close watch on
a member of staff it was a lanky
faceless monster in that garish uniform
with a bulbous oversized head and long
arms hanging slack like pulled taffy
dragging its knuckles along the ground
as it stumbled along darcy thought it
darkly funny how stupid they could look
in the daytime like crash test dummies
rejected from the assembly line bear
stood close by he never gave any of them
his real name so they took to calling
him bear because he was big hairy and
would probably tear you to shreds if you
got on his bad side he wielded the
largest club of all a customized
creation with sharp objects sticking out
of it on all sides it cleaved the heads
of many staff members off their bodies
bears seemed to relish the task of
putting those monsters down for him it
was easy and fun that's why he was an
essential asset on these missions a
berserker most of the grunts shoveled as
much food as they could carry an ikea
branded tupperware and coolers the more
they gathered the longer it would take
for them to be forced out beyond the
safe walls of the haven they built
inside this swedish flat pack hell they
all made do with what they had in here
it was all they could really do two
members of the team were unaccounted for
cyril and joseph would pass for
reconnaissance experts down here they
seemed to have an innate sense of
direction as though they were somehow in
tune with the ikea itself they would be
sent out on scouting missions searching
for resources food other survivors and
most prized of all potential escape
routes it was a dream a fantasy that
someday one of them would find the exit
and lead the rest of them to salvation
through it alice had been trapped in the
infinite ikea for six years going on
seven now she had long since given up on
dreams of escape all they could do was
accept their situation
get used to it and just try to survive
under these circumstances but those
circumstances were about to change
everyone looked up when they heard
panicked breathing it was cyril
just cyril the party clutched their
weapons just that little bit tighter
unsure of what had happened their rules
were clear scouting duos must never ever
separate under any circumstances getting
lost in the store and being isolated
when the lights went out would be a
death sentence so if cyril was returning
alone frightened tears streaking down
his face then something truly awful had
happened he told alice and the rest of
the group that something had attacked
him and joseph when alice told him that
was impossible that the staff wouldn't
show active aggression until lights out
until someone attacked them first cyril
shook his head and let out a heaving sob
he told them that the creature that
attacked them wasn't a member of staff
it was something else entirely something
he'd never seen inside the ikea before a
true monster whatever this creature was
it moved around a corner incredibly fast
it spoke in a way that was almost human
but something was off about it something
that sent a chill down cyril's spine
just thinking about it he recalled that
the creature was large and blob-like
flesh-colored with long grasping
tendrils that whipped and flailed
unnaturally these tendrils had wrapped
around and grasped joseph he hadn't been
quick enough the two of them were too
shocked by the sight of it to react in
time and then it was already too late it
grabbed joseph and yanked him off into
an adjoining isle cyril still remembered
his haunting screams getting quieter and
quieter as he moved further out of sight
on some level everyone hoped that cyril
was lying it was preferable to believe
that he himself had snapped and murdered
joseph for some unknown reason as
opposed to some new stronger and even
more dangerous creature that was now
inside the ikea was this some kind of
upgrade as they acclimated to the
environment adapted gotten better at
surviving here had the ikea in turn
created deadlier countermeasures to
destroy them all just when you thought
you had a handle on things but if cyril
was telling the truth and there was some
kind of creature lurking in the store or
potentially more than just one then they
could be in danger just standing here
they gathered up the group along with
any supplies worth taking and set off
back to their community they would need
to deliver the bad news so they could
potentially prepare for the worst it was
just one of the many communities housed
within
scp-3008 many have theorized over the
years that the infinite ikea acts as a
kind of nexus point for ikeas all across
the multiverse
accounting for the truly insane number
of people who have gone missing without
a trace into the building over the years
there were children who had been born in
the ikea raised in the ikea know nothing
but the ikea nobody knew an exact number
for sure but it was more than possible
that the population of a small country
resided within its walls sometimes
communities would fracture and fall
apart occasionally due to a lack of
resources or infighting other times due
to an overwhelming attack from the staff
that physically destroyed the settlement
often leaving many of its members dead
in the process those who weren't picked
off while wandering the store in the
following days would likely integrate
into other nearby communities as
refugees life was cruel in the infinite
ikea by the time alice and her party
returned to their community it was
almost lights out they spoke to the
community leaders and informed them of
joseph's tragic disappearance as well as
this awful new creature that cyril
claimed had taken him they thought it
best not to inform the rest of the
community tonight it might hurt their
focus and cause unnecessary panic alice
agreed to join the watch that night she
could feel something wrong in the air
even more so than usual there was
something terrible in this anomalous
ikea alice stood atop the furniture wall
with several other rangers as the lights
flickered off the distinctive calls
sounded across the store from the
activated staff members
it was almost soothing in its
familiarity compared to the frightening
thoughts that cyril had left swimming
through her mind the staff she could
handle it was at least the devil she
knew and there were worse beasts than
the devil out there she knew it in her
bones they killed a few staff members
that happened to wander towards the
community and began beating their
deformed fists against the walls all
standard procedure but as alice's eyes
adjusted to the darkness she saw a huge
shape in the distance it looked like a
mountain that breathed
a huge wobbling mass of flesh moving
impossibly fast for a creature of its
size it was so much vaster than the
creature that cyril had described
earlier was this a different one or had
it simply gotten bigger either way it
was coming straight towards them the
community came alive in sudden panic
every able-bodied adult grabbed their
weapons and prepared for the fight of
their lives behind the wall whatever
this monster was they needed to kill it
as quickly as possible before it
destroyed everything they built sadly
for everyone inside the community this
was one fight that none of them were
prepared for the beast crashed into the
furniture wall crushing it inwards
people struck at the monster's immense
and terrible flesh with their weapons
making awful wet slaps but seeming to
cause no lasting impact it just kept
rolling in grasping everyone it could
with its long sinewy tendrils but the
horrors were only just beginning with
the wall destroyed the staff began to
pour in chanting in monstrous unison
it was a massacre perhaps one of the
worst that the inside of the infinite
ikea had ever seen while the community
battled the giant flesh beast the forces
of the staff swarmed and overwhelmed
them darcy was tangled in the
nightmarish tentacles of the beast bear
was surrounded by a truly insurmountable
number of staff members each one bawling
their terrible fists and beating him to
death somewhere cyril screamed though
his scream was soon cut short alice
watched in horror as everything she'd
known was destroyed alice realized her
friends were dead and her community was
in ruins she grabbed her spear and did
the only thing she could she ran she ran
from the lost cause that had once been
her life tears running down her cheeks
what had even happened what the hell had
that great monster been the ikea's trump
card she ran aimlessly for as long as
she could then walked and eventually
limped she went on for hours getting
lost deeper and deeper into unknown
territory she'd stop when she was dead
why not she had little left to live for
but like the holy grail when she
eventually truly gave up and stopped
looking for salvation it found its way
to her as she turned a corner down a
mysterious aisle she saw something that
she hadn't seen in years glass double
doors she stifled the sob could it be
the way out of here after all this time
and it was
the world escape she lost everything but
regained this outside dawn was breaking
after years the great red sun
it was the most beautiful thing she'd
ever seen in her life she took a deep
breath
smiled and stepped into the light now go
check out how to actually beat scp-3008
the infinite ikea and scp-001 when day
breaks for more insights into the
nightmares we've been experiencing in
today's episode of scp explained